[Music]
congratulations your kubernetes
application is in production and the
number of services you own are growing
but as you scale your services in
production you also need to scale your
monitoring
after all you can't fix what you don't
Monitor and your monitoring needs to be
as reliable as your application
Prometheus is the standard kubernetes
monitoring system which helps you
collect store query and alert on metrics
important to your applications and
infrastructure managing Prometheus at
scale to handle increasingly large
metric volumes can be a huge operational
challenge this can be a thankless task
and it creates operational debt that
takes team members away from what your
users really care about the quality of
your app
Google Cloud managed service for
Prometheus is designed to help you scale
by removing operational toil from tasks
like shardy and Prometheus servers
managing complex scrape configurations
and scaling Prometheus servers to make a
global data source
and when I say Global I mean it manage
service for Prometheus enables users to
collect metrics from both kubernetes and
VM environments at incredible scale
without operational overhead by
leveraging Monarch Google's own globally
available and scalable time series
database
Monarch holds over 2 trillion time
series in memory so you won't be limited
on how many metrics you can store
together
and if you're on Prem or using another
non-gke kubernetes provider you can
easily send metrics from non-gke
clusters with managed service for
Prometheus
so you also won't have to worry about
lock-in as manage service for Prometheus
lets you ingest any Prometheus metric
and because manage service for
Prometheus includes two years of metric
retention by default you'll be able to
use those metrics to create the most
accurate assessment of your business
possible based on years of data for
those getting started with Prometheus
for the first time manage service for
Prometheus helps make Google kubernetes
engine even easier to use with
maintained metric collectors
instead of configuring infrastructure
managed collectors let you configure
Prometheus just by applying simple yaml
files Google Cloud handles the rest
manage service for Prometheus supports
any application that uses promql making
it an In-Place replacement for running
your own Prometheus servers which means
you can keep your existing Prometheus
alerts and your existing grafana
dashboards or use our Integrations in
out-of-the-box dashboards in Cloud
monitoring which supports promql as well
you can also query over 1500 Google
cloud system metrics at no cost using
promql right alongside your Prometheus
metrics in either Cloud monitoring or
grafana to get started you need to take
two steps confirm manage service for
Prometheus is running in your gke
cluster and deploy Prometheus collectors
these can be deployed alongside your
existing Prometheus servers these
collectors will be configured to write
metrics directly to manage service for
Prometheus
then connect clients such as grafana or
other tools you use to read Prometheus
metrics from manage service for
Prometheus and that's it with managed
service for Prometheus whether you're
using gke on-prem or running another
kubernetes platform you can spend less
time configuring monitoring
infrastructure and more time adding the
next big feature to your app it's that
simple so if you want to kick the tires
go to the console and enable manage
service for Prometheus and if you're not
quite ready to spin it up but want to
learn more be sure to check out the docs
at cloud.google.com monitoring to learn
more
foreign
[Music]